well it is on a good evening to you
there are so many uh different aspects
to it from a technical perspective where
you could say there are some possible
scenarios where this break in time could
have a significant impact on exactly how
the authorities here in the u.s are
allowed to prosecute cases of
possible terrorist intent and other
possible intelligence uses so there are
going to be some areas of difficulty as
some ongoing investigations may be
affected by it although they say that
there they can continue those but
nonetheless the fact that this
program has actually been stopped has a
significant impact on our ability as the
national security apparatus to actually
work in concert not only with law
enforcement agencies here in the us but
also with law enforcement agencies in
great britain and in other countries
well yes but where are those gaps
because it's true is it not that any
investigation that's already up and
running can continue so where are your
concerns
my main concerns would be anna with the
idea that there may be some new
information that is derived from the
technical collection methods so when
that happens the the big issue here is
will they follow under the previous
investigations or will they be
considered a new investigation so
basically any new investigation any uh
uncovering of a boston bomb plot for
example or something similar to that
that is
a completely fresh investigation that
will be a significant issue uh other
areas include this there's a degree of
continuity that is established with
these collection operations and when
that continuity is broken even be it
inadvertently that will also have an
adverse impact on these kinds of uh of
situations and on the investigatory
process so there are some significant
concerns there and once you lose that
continuity it becomes very hard to
regain that continuity not impossible
but it's much more difficult from an
investigatory standpoint
what about when that hiatus ends and we
get the freedom act in a matter of hours
that's a watered-down version some would
say of the patriot act it ends the bulk
collection of domestic telephone
metadata doesn't it
that's a direct result of edward
snowden's revelations and the fact that
the senate has voted in favor of it it's
a vindication of him isn't it
to an extent it is but i think this
debate should have happened anyways and
in fact it probably should have happened
in the wake of 9 11 but uh you know as
dr boyce pointed out that is not a uh
was not a politically opportune moment
to have that debate however you know
having been where we've been it becomes
very important for us as a nation to
realize that there are certain limits to
governmental surveillance powers as well
as facts that we have to deal with such
as there's a threat out there uh there's
certain things that have to happen in
order to protect us against that threat
so the constitution in the u.s does two
things it uh of course enshrines the
freedoms that are in the bill of rights
but it also gives the us government or
the federal government the power to
actually protect the nation and those
two things appear to be in conflict and
of course the patriot act and now the
usa freedom act uh were and are designed
to
actually bridge that gap and that's
that's really what uh you know where
this
becomes a challenge because there are
certain things in the technical world
that become very difficult to handle if
you don't handle them in exactly the
right way okay so will america be better
or worse protected under the usa freedom
act
well somewhat worse and the reason for
that is because the usa freedom act
actually uh does not allow as it's
currently written does not allow for the
following of individuals what is
important uh right now in in terms of
what the patriot acts provisions are is
the fact that you can follow an
individual even if he changes his phone
uh swaps out a sim card or changes from
a phone device to a tablet or something
like that
that is very important to be able to do
that and i think uh in many cases the
argument against the patriot act also
misses the key point that what we're
doing is we're trying to go after a
threat we're not trying to go after the
data per se that's just what how the
importance of the data is is how we're
looking at this and so it needs to be
stated i think very clearly that when
you have threats that we deal with both
in the uk and the us it becomes very
important for us to find where those
threats are and find the best means
least intrusive means to go after those
threats so this uh the current version
of the freedom act will have some
difficulty i will present some
difficulty i think to investigators but
i it is not something that is
insurmountable at this stage from a
technical standpoint